By now, most film fans know that when the
credits roll on a Marvel Studios movie, the
real fun is about to begin.
That's because Marvel loves to set up future
franchise installments with teasers, Easter
eggs, and inside jokes "hidden" in scenes
during the credits.
Usually, this means one or two small bits
during or after the credits, but with Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2, writer-director James
Gunn has taken things to a whole new level
with five — yes, five! — credits scenes.
Some are important, and some are just goofy,
but either way, we've got you covered with
explanations for every credits scene in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2.
"Who else is gonna do it?"
"Awesome!"
Oh, and just so everyone's on the same page...spoilers
ahead.
The Arrow
In the first bonus scene, Yondu's right hand
man Kraglin wears his former captain's robotic
fin to try and harness the power of his whistle-controlled
arrow.
Of course, it goes horribly wrong.
It looks like a funny scene, but actually
this is all a very complicated Easter egg
referencing the ascension of Kang the Conqueror
in Avengers Forever #9, and… no, just kidding.
This scene is exactly what it seemed like:
a funny one-off joke.
Hey, not every scene has to be filled with
secret meaning — okay?
The Original Guardians
Unlike the first credits scene, the second
is actually jam-packed with Marvel Comics
lore.
Those Ravagers who show up for Yondu's funeral?
Some of them are actually members of the original
Guardians of the Galaxy team from the 1970s
comic books.
Stakar, Martinex, Charlie-27, and Aleta are
all original flavor Guardians, while Mainframe
and Krugarr are also important characters
in the old school Guardians of the Galaxy
comic book universe.
And considering the big name actors Marvel
signed up for the roles, like Sylvester Stallone,
Michelle Yeoh, and Ving Rhames, chances are
pretty good we're going to see a lot more
of these guys in future movies.
Even if Stallone doesn't have the best track
record with comic book movies.
"Why did you judge me?"
"You killed innocent people."
"The means to an end."
"You started a massacre!"
"I caused a revolution!"
"You betrayed the law!"
"Lawwwwww!"
Adam Warlock
If you were wondering why the people in your
theater erupted with screams of pure joy during
the third credits scene, the answer is Adam
Warlock, the mystery being inside the metal
cocoon built by the vengeful high priestess,
Ayesha.
Marvel fans have been eagerly awaiting Warlock's
arrival in the movie universe because the
gold-skinned cosmic savior has been a key
player in basically every important Thanos
storyline in comics history.
Adam Warlock is Thanos' archenemy, an avatar
of life dedicated to stopping Thanos and his
obsession with death.
With Thanos set to finally take center stage
in 2018's Avengers: Infinity War, fans have
been wondering how Marvel would manage to
tell the story without Adam Warlock.
Now we can all finally rest easy — if we
can stop freaking out.
I am Groot
The fourth credits scene is pretty much just
a self-explanatory joke about Baby Groot growing
up to become Teen Groot.
We're not sure if this means Teen Groot will
be in the sequel, or if this is a bridge to
explain why he's all grown up as Adult Groot
in the team's next appearance.
But considering this brief clip is funnier
than just about any half-hour family sitcom
on primetime television right now, we can't
be the only ones hoping ABC develops a Growing
Up Groot spinoff, right?!
Stan the Man
For nearly 20 years now, Stan Lee has been
making cameos in Marvel movies.
As a result, a fan theory developed along
the way that Stan isn't actually playing different
characters, but instead is a disguised member
of the alien race known as The Watchers, who
observe and record stories of mankind without
interfering in events.
Now Lee and director James Gunn have confirmed
it with a fantastic bit where Stan is telling
a group of Watchers about all the stories
he's participated in — which, of course,
are the other Marvel movies.
It further proves what we've known all along:
Stan truly is The Man.
"You know, I guess one person can make a difference.
Enough said."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!